Tên xích một trong năm nay đây, hoàn thành một nghiệm phòng học.
Một nâmer bà dự ăn sự kiến đưa vật sự dụng, hơn một nghiệm phòng học xí mới,
và gần tạm trong phòng học tăng thêm.
Bối tổng mưu từ vào khoảng 4 ba nghìn tạm trong tý động.
Đây này tháng bây đã có 2 mình tương dự ăn hoàn thành.
Bối 3 trong xong mình tương phòng học mới, từ nay đến chương ngày khai sàng,
thành phố tiếp tục truyện khai 2 mình chính dự ăn có lại.
Hô nơi trong 7 mình tương tý động cũng được dành đi sự chữa nâng cấp cửa sở vật chết
và mua 3 chăm tý vị cho các chiều hần.
Đây tổ chức sẽ học 1 chăm phần chăm học sinh tiểu học tại thành phố được học 2 buổi 1 ngày.
Tý lẹ học sinh học 2 buổi 1 ngày, chúng học cái sử.
Gần bệnh 2 phần chăm.
Chúnga phụ thông đã chính 2 phần chăm.
Thánh phố đã một tiêu tương năm học 2 ím thông trong 2 ím thông chăm 2, 2 ím thông chăm 3 tấm.
Tất cả các sự giữa giữa phụ thông tổ chức sẽ học 2 buổi 1 ngày.
Ngành giáo giúp cũng đá hoàn thiện phương ảm sắp sếp trứng lớp, rõ phían và cơ sở và chát.
Dự kính chình 2 chương ngày mắm thánh tấm bỏ đà bột địch nè mọc mới.